I think there's a line in my college
application essay that goes math and
science hadn't found me my mother always
says I'd be a Broadway star
[Laughter]
the MTA player s lab is the Supra first
ever of its kind here at MIT
collaboration between playwriting
students and theatre professionals so I
took eight playwrights into Maya
playwrights workshop this spring and
each of those eighth graders is getting
a professional staged reading this
weekend as part of the lab seeing the
process of a play going from an idea to
something that might be executable to
something that might be publishable
that's been a great experience the first
two readings both of them sold out so we
have over 50 students here in the
audience and it's mostly students so
it's exciting than a lot of young MIT
kids who have probably never seen a
staged reading before coming here to
support their fellow students works and
being inspired by science than my play
that you saw as like science fiction
being inspired by science and like
wanting so much from the world and
always questioning like as
technologically advanced so much are we
like morally advanced you know redoing
anything that's like are we on par with
the things that we're creating to you
storytelling which is really what
Clarets or you know essentially learning
it is really gonna be useful whether or
not it's about making a presentation or
writing an essay or building a website I
think that like whatever you're doing
you're kind of telling a story in some
way and so if you learn how stories are
made and you learn what some of the sort
of interlocking parts of stories are
even if you're just learning the rules
so as to break them I think it's kind of
good to sort of think about what you're
doing as an act of storytelling
[Music]
you